2020 will be a year we'll always
remember and one that has forever
changed our country the coronavirus
claimed the lives of more than 300
thousand americans
just in 2020 businesses closed and tens
of millions of people filed for
unemployment
we also elected a new president and
witnessed the growing demand to end
racial injustice this morning we're
looking back at the pivotal moments and
people
who shape 20 20. the deadly coronavirus
outbreak is spreading faster raising new
concerns
all around the globe hospitals are
beginning to face dire conditions icu's
are packed and beds are filling up
quickly
there's no words i can describe this it
doesn't get any more critical than this
it does not you keep hearing that young
people are not as affected by this has
that been your experience
you can tell that the 27 year old i
activated that way we are using
everything that is available it's like
being a fireman and running into a
burning building with flip-flops and a
bikini on
schools are closed businesses are
following suit and more and more people
are working from home plan a don't go in
a crowd
plan b if you do make sure you wear a
mask they're not just telling you to
wear masks they're now
requiring it resistance to covert safety
guidelines is so strong that citizens
have sued to have them removed
when those mask guidelines were unveiled
the president made a point of saying
that he would not wear one i
wore one in this back area but i didn't
want to give the press the pleasure of
seeing it
the mask is not a political statement
on wall street stock fell so quickly
trading was suspended we have not seen
job losses like this probably since the
great depression
you know you're going to lose money i
might lose the whole business
new challenges for educators and
families trying to get through this
school year
when school slows down in march that
wasn't distance learning
that was emergency learning who's
anxious
about going back into the classroom
everybody the american death toll
has now passed 300 000 since this
pandemic began
behind every one of those numbers is an
individual
while some were known to the world
others were known only to loved ones
this coronavirus does not discriminate
it is an equal opportunity heartbreaker
for survivors
we will beat this the first coronavirus
vaccines are underway here in the united
states this is unbelievable oh my god
the greatest medical achievements that
this planet has ever seen
healthcare workers got their first shots
many after months on the front lines
we're going to get it we're going to get
it right we're going to vaccinate the
whole country
i feel hopeful i see the finish line the
light is brighter in the tunnel
this is a life-changing election this
will determine what america is going to
look like for a long long time
americans came out to vote early by mail
and
on election day it hangs on a razor's
edge every vote
matters they're really going to matter
in some of these states you
chose joe biden as the next president
of the united states of america
this is not a political opinion it is a
mathematical computation
i won by the way but you know find that
out
at this point the trump campaign has not
provided any
evidence of fraud i understand the
disappointment i've lost a couple times
myself
but now let's give each other a chance
rising anger over the alleged police
murder of george floyd
they are here to stop police violence
and to demand equality
chance of black lives matter echoed
around the world
mr trump doubled down on his threat to
deploy the u.s military
to control violence in the streets
setting this truck on fire right here
behind me is how some responded
to the authorities what we are seeing is
a lot of destruction the kind of
destruction that's going to take
years to recover from former police
officer derek chovin is currently
charged with third degree murder
we got targets on my backs
and it's the truth
louisville police shot and killed 26
year old brianna taylor in her apartment
the kentucky attorney general saying
those officers were not charged because
they acted in self-defense
they said there were other possible
charges that we considered but nothing
that we could make stick
people ask me all the time what they can
do for me i tell them
say her name it's what you can do for me
please continue
to say her name brianna tyler the
idea that we are helpless it's just an
idea that i don't accept
change has to come it's happening
far too many times
we want people we're one family we all
live in the same house
the world house we must say wake up
america
wake up congressman john lewis of
georgia an
icon of the nation's civil rights
movement has died
never gave up you cannot give up you
cannot give in
you have to be persistent sometimes
getting in a little trouble leads to big
major life-changing changes which is
what you did
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg has died she was tiny in
stature but she was so mighty when it
came to influence
people asked me when would you be
satisfied with the number of women on
the court
when there are nine as americans are
remembering the life of justice ginsburg
republicans and democrats in congress
are fighting over
who will replace her and when amy coney
barrett has
become a supreme court justice the
senate confirmed 48 year old barrett
almost entirely
along party lines
beirut lebanon is in chaos from a
massive deadly explosion
a quarter of a million people made
homeless in a matter of seconds
the united states military killed the
number one terrorist anywhere in the
world
kasem salamani the world is a better
place without him
the problem is that comes at a very high
cost
this is the scene of iran's revenge
attack
against u.s troops here in iraq
aging wildfires in california oregon and
washington state are burning out of
control there is a neighborhood believe
it or not on the other side of all vans
that fire crews right now simply can't
get to the smoke is so thick it's hard
to see
it's the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life this was
our happy place it's nothing now it's a
wasteland
her name is laura and she is no joke
the strongest storm to hit this area on
record
passed directly over the location where
i am standing
right now the wind was so violent
we could actually feel our hotel shaking
we have
thousands and thousands of our fellow
citizens whose lives are upside down
may you both rest in peace and have fun
in heaven
until we meet again one day tributes are
pouring in from around the world to kobe
bryant bryant and his 13 year old
daughter gianna and seven other people
were killed when their helicopter
crashed in california
kobe bryant transcended sports his
legacy certainly did
bryant on the move with the jumper
he inspired a whole generation of people
that's quite a gift
god i love you guys what can i say
mamba out
when i get to heaven i'm gonna shake
god's hand
[Music]
festivus for the rest of us
what it is we love you out that's very
kind thank you
costco 19.95
everything that you fought for was not
for yourself
it was for those that come after
thank you very much for these great
years together god bless you all and
i hope i see you again real soon
[Music]
liftoff of the falcon line and crew
dragons
go
two nasa astronauts on an historic
spacex mission woke up on board the
international space station
we like a big challenge and by gosh we
certainly got one if there's a headline
here it's this
america's back in a space launching
business
an unprecedented announcement from
prince harry and his wife meghan markle
the couple says that they are stepping
down as senior members of the family
from brexit to mexico it's been widely
reported
that megan and harry are living at your
place in los angeles can you tell us how
they're doing
i'm sorry i think i just lost i just
lost you i just lost you gail i'm sorry
we have a bad really bad connection
[Music]
[Applause]
right
you